thank you guys for being here by the way  you guys whatever good evening welcome  to the academy we started off just  basically going through the script and  thinking well how are we going to  visualize this you know but but  specifically every day was hard from The  Academy Theater we can be honest about  that right all the apparatus that goes  into making movies cameras crew lights  booms mics all that stuff who cares  about lenses  this room cares  bag eventually weighed about 65 pounds  what did that give you as an actor  um back pain back pain yeah people are  trying to make a statement we're just  trying to tell our story with all these  wonderful people we were all just in it  so you had a great time making it was  amazing  did I fight a cat I've gotta like I  gotta up my game